they're you a shoplifter oh yes I wasn't  shoplifting we're going down the wrong a  vanilla my mama was in and out of jail  she was a career criminal and my dad was  a career criminal they did two different  kind of crimes yeah but my mama was  always like man if you're gonna do some  crime you owe me like this my first time  I got in trouble I mom I'm gonna tell  you I stole the box of Boston baked  beans but it wasn't a regular trouble I  getting the kind of baked beans rattling  in my pocket that's how I got caught so  she tell me how dare you steal a  little-ass box of baked beans with  little stakes in the back in the meat  section if he's gonna steal don't you go  to jail for no goddamn box of baked  beans those like you know where you  write mama  [Music]